hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday and since it's Sunday I'm
able to do a morning video and this game
was suggested to me by a subscriber and
I'm glad it was it's quite an amazing
game it was played in 2002 between
Lawrence strength and the Desmond Stan
and the Lawrence strength is a manager
commentator coach author and founder of
the elite minds group he's a man on a
mission to get the most talented minds
the recognition they deserve and how
he's a pretty great guy I do follow him
on Twitter and you know I check out his
daily content and I will put a link to
his Twitter profile in the description
below so you can check it out and I
didn't really find that much information
about mr. Desmond 10 other than he was a
feed a master and the problem is there
is a famous Singaporean actor named
Desmond tan so whatever you google
Desmond tan about you just get the
Singaporean actor so yeah but I'm pretty
sure that this is his picture although
I'm pretty sure it's an old one but
nevertheless it's the game I'm
interested in so let's see this game
Lawrence is white and mr. Desmond tan is
black we have d4 Knight to f6 and the
Lawrence goes for Bishop to g5 the Trump
offski attack we have e 6 e 4 we have h6
forcing White's to decide what to do
with the dark square Bishop Bishop
captures on f6 Queen captures on f6 and
Queen to d2 and okay we have d5 Knight
to c3 c6 we have a queenside castle and
Bishop to b4 and e5 forcing the Queen
somewhere else other than here we have
Queen back to d8 and if different black
would play Bishop captures on c3 Queen
captures on c3 this would be this would
be better for white so the Queen
retreats we have a three and our Bishop
d7 of course black doesn't want to allow
Bishop captures on c3 as he does have a
light square bishop on all of his bones
or on light squares this would be pretty
pretty dull to play for black
Lawrence plays f4 we have a five Knight
to f3 and now b5 and it seems like black
really expanded on the Queen
said and is ready to go for the attack
would be for so Lauren stops this he
plays a for himself first and the best
move here for black would probably be
before but it does seem that white will
be able to lock down the position after
before
so instead doesn't plays at Bishop to b4
we have Queen to e3 now Bishop captures
on c3 Queen captures on c3 and B
captures on a4 and we have h4 and not
mean to b6 and this is a this is a very
nice position as it does seem that it's
black was on the attack now black has
some ideas of playing Bishop to a6
exchanging this Bishop here and then
maybe maneuvers like Knight a six to be
four to eight to pawn pushes like a 3c5
White has to take all of this into
consideration and white did consider all
of this and Lawrence played rook to h3
and this is I always enjoy a good rook
lift this is what I really like
we have Bishop to a6 now going for that
Bishop exchange and now Lawrence plays
rook to g3 and well this is pretty much
the critical position of the game here
mr. Desmond should have played something
like winter before maybe offering a
queen exchanged you know fix his pawn
structure maybe capture the bishop on f1
but he actually decided as this g7
ponies attacked maybe even Ruby g8 was
playable but he decided to castle as he
didn't think there was any danger here
but danger was actually lurking and
Lawrence here played f5 and already you
can see that all of a sudden white is on
the attack if he gets f6 in in there it
will be very unpleasant for black we
have each captures on f5 and now Queen
to e3 and this is again a very nice
position as it seems that white rook
came all the way from h1 to g3 white
queen got all help from c1 from c3 to
III and it seems that all black was
managed all black managed to do in the
past four moves was to play Bishop to a
six so this is quite an accomplishment
for white we have a king to h8 not
allowing Queen
choice on h6 and now Lawrence pushes
East six and well probably a again the
best move would be to capture this point
but this is again well white would be
better here but Desmond played f6 and we
have e seven now the threat is of course
e8 black stops this would rook to e8 and
now Lawrence plays Knight to e5 and well
can this night be captured of course the
pawn cannot be captured as an IG six
check picks up the rook but can can
black to capture this night
if for example F captures on e5 you get
Queen captures on e5 and how do you stop
Queen captures on g7 well you don't have
the real captures on e7 and Queen
captures on e7 probably the best defense
is something like Queen to a7 but then
simply Queen to f8 would check King 287
and rook to e1 and this is this is
completely winning for white as a black
can't develop and this knife cannot come
into the game if knife if Knight to d7
then simply Queen captures and g7 is
checkmate and white is threatening Queen
captures on f5 here with rook to e8 and
this is completely cry completely
crushing so after Knight to e5 Desmond's
tried rooked a7 now defending this
seventh rank and also preparing to
capture here but we have rope captures
on g7 and this is this is very nice as
Mike doesn't really have a better move
than to capture the rook if he would
play something like rook gave a captures
when he seventh and simply captures rook
captures and ninety g6 check picking up
the rook and the white is winning so
after rope to g7 Desmond ten captured
the rook King captures here and here we
have a queen to g3 with check so f7 is
covered FA discovered the black King has
to go to the H file so cling to h8 and
now we have nine to f7 check King - h7
and now h5 the threat of course is Queen
to g6 checkmate and how does black stop
this well there is only one move he
plays rook to g8 and it seems like white
like
like he's defending but here comes the
the beautiful punchline Lawrence plays
he ate and promotes to another queen and
in this position mr. Desmond tan
resigned the game as whatever whatever
black plays it's checkmate next move if
if he for example captures the queen and
g3 then simply Quinta h8 is instant
checkmate
if he decides to capture the Queen on eh
then again Queen to g6 is instant
checkmate and of course something like
capturing the Knights here is well
that's just silly
wink after Sun g8 is instant checkmate
so doesn't Desmond ten in this position
he resigned and well this this beautiful
game was created it's a twenty seven
move game so not really Canton couldn't
really be classified as a miniature but
nevertheless a beautiful game so yeah
thank you for suggesting this game to me
and I do hope you you enjoyed this game
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will help I will see you
soon have a great Sunday